what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John we're gonna watch the trailer
for Godzilla King Munsters king of the
monsters before we do that I'm gonna
give it patron today shout out to a man
named Curt Anderson very lovely
gentleman just take a look at this guy's
photo look how happy this guy looks this
guy actually has a crazy story that we
revealed in one video a while ago up to
this day he has told me he has traveled
49 states in all of America Wow looking
and a traveler that's a catch right
there ladies or men I don't know what
your orientation is I just wanted to say
man thank you for being part of our
patreon page Godzilla might be king of
the monsters but you were the king of
the probably world let's do this Wow
we what the section much crazier already
know what's happening in whoa
[Music]
like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection okay
the board's original and rightful rulers
and the Titans nice DC yeah for
thousands of years these creatures
around the world our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee see my
nipple chosen is towel holy crap
yeah
[Music]
okay I know our connection
eleven screaming I love it get the nose
wheelie
laughs
[Music]
the king he was the King Jabin
more potent
Oh
[Music]
Wow really taking that criticism to
hardly you didn't see and I've got Zilla
in the first movie that looks way more
action way more epic scale yeah huge go
huge usko best dinosaurs the best you're
probably gonna get a lot more Godzilla
in here you get agador in here you get
Mothra on here I heard grodanz in here I
don't know if I don't know if I missed
him as I was kind of just taking away of
all the spectacle you got so many more
actors in this movie and I like Kyle
Chandler in here Farmiga million Bobby I
didn't look at the IMDB toll right now
I'm like you got Bradley Whitford milli
Bobby Brown Vera Farmiga Sally Hawkins
Kyle Chandler Zhang Ziyi or is he saying
'she's credit here Thomas Middleditch
you know Ken Watanabe of course nice to
see him return actually I'm not sure if
the casting of Milly Bobby Brown is
perfect or distracting it looks so
stranger things when you're watching
your performance really but it works
though would know what stranger things
is yeah she's found her typecast yeah
that much we're gonna have a lot of her
for years to come but this looks like
it's really gone for the doom and gloom
scale this feels like it's gonna be a
lot more heavy with its action it's
monster nest is a picnic I cannot wait
for this film
gonna be a great IMAX experience Oh king
of the monsters is like the perfect
subtitle for this because this really
does look like an all-out brawl for
Earth between the answers you know and I
wonder if it's gonna have that tone
because this is from Michael Dougherty
who's done like these horror centric
films that are a lot more fun these
things I have like sharp edges but are
also kind of darkly humorous yeah and I
don't get it the sense of that humor at
all is really know so I don't know if
it's just the first trailer and it's a
good transition after what the first
Godzilla gave us I would kind of like
some of that fun in here but if we don't
get it if this trailer is the perfect
representation of the tone I'm still on
board for it cuz this feels emotionally
heavy yeah I feel like everything
they've said in the lead up suggests
that this is gonna be at least more fun
than the first one but I do appreciate
what they did with this trailer because
it is that sort of slow
yeah it music like gravitas imagery but
like the classical sounds they use and
everything and just the images they
chose made this look insane absolutely
yeah what more do you want I mean what
more do you want this trailer gave you
exactly what you wanted this global
scale destruction looks like the earth
is fine for a bit but then it's going to
become an annihilation this is awesome
this is awesome alright guys well this
Godzilla trailer satisfy you let us know
in the comments below you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly q and A's music video covered
would love to have you aren't bit here
become a patron eject today